[Music]  hey guys i'm lauren zima on the bachelor  in paradise season finale we had  multiple tear-filled engagements and one  tear-filled not engagement first let's  take a look at the three happy moments  were you freaking married  will you marry me so exciting to see  grant and lace evident Carly and Josh  and Amanda make it all the way but one  Final Four couple did not the new  bachelor Nick vial and Jen Saviano  here's how things ended for them I've  fallen in love with you  I didn't want to get to me to fall if  you're going to catch me  guy wanted to say I was in love with you  but just like you first something in my  heart so said I can what did you guys  think of the bachelor in paradise season  finale and of how Nick let Jen down he  is gonna be our new bachelor after all  let me know over on Twitter  you